All right, take a listen to this. Um,
when we talk about making America great
again, it's important to think about
what made America great in the first
place. Now, one obvious answer to that
is that America became great by kind of
looking inward and attending to its own
problems, uh, going back to the
founders. Uh, but that is not only not
entirely true, it's not true at all. uh
right after the American founding,
Thomas Jefferson
uh found out that there were these
barbar pirates in the Middle East. Now,
they weren't attacking America. They
weren't starting war over here, but
Jefferson basically dispatched an armed
force to clobber them, to beat the heck
out of them. Why? Because they were
disrupting our interests. They were
disrupting our trade. They were hurting
our position in the world. So even
though we had this infant democracy,
collaborating bad guys is something that
we started doing from the very
beginning. Now look, whether you believe
America should be the most isolationist
nation in the world or whether you
believe America should be the most
interventionist nation in the world is
your affair. My interest here is purely
historical. And I'm here to tell you
that what you just heard about the
Barbarie states, which incidentally were
in Northwest Africa, not the Middle
East, is the exact opposite of reality.
For starters, anyone remotely familiar
with their history, knows that the
Barbary Corsaires were state sponsored
pirates sanctioned by Muslim rulers who
profited immensely by raiding European
coasts and ships and enslaving any
Christian they could get their hands on.
A business supported by Islamic law and
policy, no less. The pirates went
everywhere, even distant Iceland, to
collect and sell slaves to fellow
Muslims. Second, the claim that these
pirates weren't attacking America is
utterly absurd. Right after the American
colonies won independence from Britain,
they lost British naval protection. As a
result, American merchant vessels became
juicy targets for the seaborn jihad.
Starting in 1785, Barbrey pirates began
capturing American ships such as the
Maria and Dalphin and enslaving their
crews. These sailors suffered
horrendously. As one American captain,
Richard O'Brien, wrote in a desperate
letter to Thomas Jefferson, "Our
sufferings are beyond our expression or
your conception." If you're interested,
I go into some disturbing details
concerning what Barbrey pirates did to
American and European slaves in Sword
and Scimitar, chapter 8. Anyway, the
newly formed United States government
responded by paying ransoms and
tributes, known in Islamic law as Jiza,
to release whichever sailors they could
and stop the kidnappings. These payments
amounted to a staggering 16% of the
federal budget at one point. In other
words, the US initially tried diplomatic
negotiations and tribute payments to
keep the peace in line with what
European powers had also done for
generations. Then in 1786, after meeting
with a Muslim ambassador in an effort to
develop friendly relations, Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams sent a
remarkably telling letter to Congress.
They wrote, quote, "We took the liberty
to make some inquiries concerning the
grounds of their barbber's pretensions
to make war upon nations who had done
them no injury. And we observed that we
considered all mankind as our friends,
who had done us no wrong, nor had given
us any provocation." The ambassador
answered us that it was founded on the
laws of their prophet, that it was
written in their Quran, that all nations
who should not have acknowledged their
authority were sinners, that it was
their right and duty to make war upon
them wherever they could be found, and
to make slaves of all they could take as
prisoners, and that every Muslim who
should be slain in battle was sure to go
to paradise. When, however, the Muslim
pirates demanded a much greater tribute
than agreed to, talks collapsed and
Congress debated. The majority ended up
siding with John Adams. "We ought not to
fight them at all," said he, "unless we
determine to fight them forever." So
Jefferson's eventual decision to deploy
naval forces in 1801, that is the first
Barbary War, came after years of attacks
on American vessels and the enslavement
of their crews. After years of failed
diplomacy, escalating demands from
Barbary, and finally an outright
declaration of jihad from Tripoli
against the United States. In short, the
Barbrey Wars were not about the founding
fathers clobbering bad guys who had
disrupted their position in the world as
Duza says. Rather, it was a war
dedicated to protecting its citizens
from enslavement and putting an end to
extortionist demands of tribute. Nor
alas was the war a quick triumph lasting
as it did 5 years. The fledgling
American Navy suffered setbacks,
including the humiliating capture of the
USS Philadelphia and its crew in 1803.
The war was purely defensive, reluctant,
and reactive. Not some early example of
American interventionism or imperialism
as Duza would have us believe. And
that's just the plain old truth. Like it
or not. Bye.